Jason Satterlund, Filmmaker: We work so hard to
get through to break through, you're just trying
every step of the way to write the
screenplays, to work with the actors
and then finally someone gives you a shot and
then they Bam! They shut the door on your face.
It felt like well then what's the point?
Film Courage:
For any new filmmakers watching can you take us
through the process of making a film, all the way
from getting financing to getting cast attached,
below the line people, working all the way.
Jason: If we're talking about making a
movie specifically that's what you mean?
The general process of making the movie is of
course it starts with a script, you’ve got to get
a script from somewhere. Hopefully find financing
in some way, shape or form whether that's an
investor or credit cards or something. Usually at
that point then you find casting then it becomes
putting your crew together probably starting
with someone like a cinematographer,
deciding to look the props you move into
production and you're doing that whole
scene and then then it's post on the end of it
that's the general building blocks which are
probably fairly obvious the trick is how
do you do I mean how do you if you're
if you've never done it like how do you
even move that ball down the field at all
that's usually the big question how do I make
a movie how do you get in the world you do it
I've done three features to this
point and each one of them came about
in different ways the first one so
actually the first one I ever tried to make
did everything you were supposed to do I read
all the books I read rebel without a crew I did
I read all the books that all the filmmakers
read about independent film and whatever
I wrote a script my mom told me it was really
great and all my friends told me how great it was
I found an investor a guy who helped me with a
business plan but he was only willing to invest
in the trailer he didn't have enough money to
actually fund the whole film but he knew business
cool that's something I lack so we wrote we
did a killer trailer we set out to raise money
everybody told me you have never made a
feature so how and I was trying to raise
like a million bucks I think I was sorry budget
every investor said this is a high risk investment
and you've never made a movie so how am I
how do I know I'm ever going to see it again
and how do I know what you're doing I heard
that over and over and over again for several
years before I finally gave up it was so
demoralizing because actually the trailer we made
was good we thought for sure people would be into
it didn't work didn't work at all it was not what
the books told me that would happen it was not it
was very frustrating so here I am back square one
I got this cool movie trailer yay for a film
that doesn't exist okay so I had to go back to
the drawing board and go all right so then how do
I make a movie how do I get this thing made so I
wrote a different script and I wrote this script
based on things that I knew I had access to so
I shoot a lot of underwater stuff all right
I can I can maybe add some of that I wouldn't
recommend that an independent feature film I did
it anyway wrote this little murder mystery thing
I set out to raise forty thousand dollars forty
thousand I was thinking before thought to myself
I've shot a lot on my camera I've shot I
have a lot of experience behind the camera
I had tried to teach myself as much as I could
about filmmaking I had worked with another
director a whole bunch and he showed me how five
c stands and a couple of flags and a little light
kit can really do a lot for you so I'm like
and I learned a lot from him he taught me all
this great stuff so I bought I literally bought
five c stands handful of flags had a light kit
that's it that's all I had doorway
dolly little bit of track and okay
I can I can make a movie with just these few
elements I’ll cast my friends as the actors
wanna raise 40 grand I couldn't
raise 40 grand I raised 12.
and all the people that threw in was fantastic
they were all good friends of mine but that
still left me in this place of like man how am
I supposed to pull this off without anything
I decided well I'm gonna take
that money and use it for catering
and for the couple of rentals that
I need and I'm gonna do it anyway
so I sat out and shot for five straight weeks
I shot it during this is this is really helpful
the people I cast the first one was an actor who
was in acting school he was on his Christmas break
for a month so he was actually home for a month
that I could grab him for that was very helpful
I did not break the shoot up into tiny pieces like
a lot of people do work because that gets really
dangerous because your actors someone's going
to get married someone's going to get a haircut
trying to coordinate people for months and months
and months on end is gets increasingly difficult
to do so I tried to shoot it all in one block just
to get it knocked out and get it out of the way
so over Christmas time was a great time work is
slow gear is available sometimes crew is available
that made everything exponentially easier I paid
everybody with food had a friend do the crafty
we came up with this little and I and by
the way everything we had a crew of five
every all the lighting fit in my SUV and
the I had this little Tupperware container
with napkins forks and knives salt and pepper
things like that the k this friend of mine was
kind of helping us cater and she would fill that
up and had all the crafty in it and I could just
pull it out and wheel it to set and she would
bring like a casserole or something every morning
it was a great little system she wasn't there
all day but it was something so that the crew
was taken care of and I planned like I've never
planned before like went and looked at each
location I measured each room to make sure that
the because I wanted to know if I want to do a
doorway dolly shot through this little doorway
is it even wide enough for me to do that so I
measured it to make sure it was right and then
pre-planned out where all my shots would be so
that I could be a military operation in every
single location because I did not have the money
to to be able to do extra reshoots and things
like that so I had this giant three-ring binder
like this that with every little detail every
scene which scene came before which scene came
after so that I could meet because I didn't have
a scripty I had myself I was DP I had three film
students and I had a art department person and
a stunt coordinator like those were that was it
that's all I had so I needed to be able to
create a system to where I could do it all myself
and I did it I pulled it off now I will say it was
one of the most exhausting experiences of my life
it I actually put myself in the hospital from
exhaustion I ended up passing out in the shower
but I did it I got it done and sometimes
making your first feature will take that
to you'll have you may hopefully not you may have
to push yourself further than you ever thought
possible but if you want it this might be what you
have to do push yourself so much further than you
thought and it wasn't like I had this great day
job gig where I could afford to take all this time
off I couldn't I was living on credit cards and I
had to push and push and push now here's the thing
that film it's you can watch it if you want
it's a 12 000 movie it's never going to be
it it's a 12 it looks like a and sounds like
a 12 000 movie and it's not anything great
you can it's on Amazon it's called The
Human Trace you can watch it if you want
watch it only to inspire you to make
something better I would also tell you
at the same time go watch Christopher Nolan's
Following it was shot for like six grand so
but because Christopher Nolan made Following
he got to make Memento right sometimes it
takes that first one to get you out the
door and if no one is giving you a shot
you're just gonna have to figure out how to
give it to yourself that's what I had to do
and it took everything I had to make it happen but
I will tell you that after 25 years later it is
my most proudest accomplishment because I did
it on my own and I did it and I made it happen
you won a couple awards did okay it wasn't
ever sold for a lot of money it didn't do
we're all hoping we're all hoping that when we do
it that that's going to be the thing that opens
the door don't count on that it probably won't
hey if it happens for you that's fantastic but
be careful what how you pin your hopes on on that
one project and I learned that in the biggest way
on film number two so so film number one was
done the true indie filmmaker way which was
blood sweat and tears doing everything yourself
all of that even to the point we recorded like
all the underwater sounds by taking a microphone
and putting a condom around it and dipping it in
the swimming pool and then making underwater
sounds and did all the sound design like that
like it was it was interesting safe recording
that that's right no one got pregnant uh
so that's one way that you can do it and I will
say that the process of that now the film itself
did not open doors however from that point forward
I could tell people that I made a movie they're
not going to watch this movie that doesn't matter
I could tell people that I made the movie that
did help when it came to the second one because
I was able to tell people I've done this before
I've been through this mill before I know how to
make a two-hour story and make it hold together
the second film was done was paid for by a large
organization that they wanted to dramatize a book
so this is an interesting now this is another way
you can make films happen and I've seen people do
this because they will take a story and wrap
it around a cause if you can attach your story
to say a book like in the case of this
it was a book they wanted to dramatize
or you could come up with a cause say I don't
know voting rights or ending childhood hunger
right there are organizations that really they're
champions of this and and massive organizations
that are around it fight this kind of thing and
you can get them to partner with you you will
also have a built-in audience it's a great way
to get a film going if your film has some sort of
bent like that it'll give you a platform access to
investors and things like that. that's fantastic
and also it feels good when you get out of bed in
the morning because you're making a film that's
actually doing good like this so my next film was
like that what that means is that means two things
I'm working for a client that's
different than your own little film
this is gonna be more like what it was like
working in a studio and I'm also making a film
based on pre-existing material so I'm adapting
a book for a client so that means that I have
to work with a committee of people who are
dictating the story and they're telling me
things they want in it certain agendas that they
have that is a that is what you will run into
when you do a film for an organization
this is it's not necessarily a bad thing
it can be a very collaborative feeling in this
case it was a very positive creative experience
the the executive producer and myself are
very good friends to this day we're still
working together we made this film it's called the
record keeper it it was a wonderful experience to
make it's a steampunk sci-fi thriller about
angels and all that it was super super fun
but the organization decided at the end of it not
to release it and it's a whole long sort of story
as to why but this taught me lesson number
two which is when you tie your hopes
to what your project can do or will do
it's a dangerous place to be it's some people
refer to that as living in the future you are
I wish I could remember which sports team this
was but I know there's a famous story about
a football team that was that was playing this
game and this one team thought they had won it
and I think there was an interception or tackle or
something and team a ah that's it we won the game
and the fans started flooding the the stadium
and things like that but the play wasn't over
and the other team somehow grabbed the ball
picked it up and run it to the other end zone
and it was discovered somehow in this
crazy celebration that they actually lost
viewers may remember what this story is I can't
quite remember what it is off the top of my head
but that this is actually something that happened
this is an example of a team that got so focused
on the future of winning x going to film festival
winning winning Sundance that they completely
lost sight of where they actually were and that
was a very devastating lesson for me to learn
which was we made this film we were winning awards
people were so excited we were on set you could
feel the magic in the air as we were creating it
working with actors the story was really cool we
felt like we were on this launching pad and all
of a sudden we go launching into the stratosphere
and the organization says no and I took a tumble
off of that into a very dark place to the point
where I almost gave up making films it was so
hard because you we work so hard to get through
you to break through right you're just trying
every step of the way to write the screenplays
to work with the actors and then finally someone
gives you a shot and then they bam they shut the
door on your face it felt like well then what's
the point it just it I seriously thought about
my wife and I talked at length about
maybe we should just go teach English
in Korea or something and just give up it
was because I was pinning my hopes on what it
I thought it was gonna do up here and I lost sight
of where the reality of where it actually was
realizing this is a very real possibility this
the signs were there going along that this
could happen but I just didn't want to see it I
just believed that it would do better than that
so I recovered from that whole experience which
took some time took a lot of licking of the wounds
and eventually down the line I got back on my
feet I ended up at this fourth time I worked I
did I ended up getting a job it was a way that I
got to la and this is something very interesting
because I feel like the second film that I did
if I had lived in la things would have turned out
differently because my friend's circle would have
been different well I was living in another city
and the people that I was surrounded by and people
making movies the artists involved were just
from that city if I had been in la making this
with la people I think other it would have
been higher exposure I think the
results would have been different
I need to get down there and try to figure
out a way to make this happen so I end up
taking a full-time job which was very that after
going whoop I want to be I'm going to be famous
I’m going to work a full-time job at a
job I hate I'm the world's worst person
right so boom so I'm in this full-time
job but but while I was in this job
first of all I gave myself a time limit I'm
only going to be here for a year this is just
to get me to la so did that and while I
was in the job I thought okay I need to
get film number three off the ground I can't
let this second experience be the death of me
I can't let that be the defining moment of my
life so I went to the Austin Film Festival and I
met Dwain Worrell there and we connected and I
followed up with him this is the traditional way
how movies are supposed to be made right so we
get back to la we became fast friends he sends
me the script I couldn't put it down I love
the script so much I asked him if it was okay
if I pitched it around he said yes I went to
another film festival connected with these other
group of producers came back pissed it to them
they said that's great that's a green light now
this is the traditional way of how you want it
to happen in Hollywood right so these are three
different possible ways of how films get made
is any of them right or wrong absolutely not
but it's just a way of demonstrating
and how this actually happens
the third way I will say is has been the most
interesting because I'm working for a production
house who's done multiple films there's a great
comfort in that because they have had things
distributed way more than I have they have done
they understand the ins and outs of the other
side of the business that I'm not as familiar with
that's fantastic there's also a great because I'm
in la I have a great network of filmmakers
to choose from to help me make this thing
that's also a huge asset it's given us access
to film festivals that I didn't have before so
there's enormous value in going after a film
like that in that way now the film is about
to release at the time of this recording so we
will see how this particular process goes but
so how is a film made it's it's in any
way that you possibly can it's you you
I had to put myself in the hospital make the first
one I had to take a job I hated for the third
and all of them were worth it because once you're
there and you're doing it it is the the dream that
we've all striven for it's real it's magic it's
it's fantastic it's the best job in the world.
What do you like about this video?